es sind tatsächlich riesige mengen
steine die auf dem pazifik drei mehrere
millionen brocken aus vulkanischem
gestein sie bilden eine fläche von
unglaublichen 150 quadratkilometern das
ist tatsächlich so groß wie bochum oder
freiburg und das vulkanische gestein
könnte auch zu einer schlimmen gefahr
für das ökosystem werden klicks um
science-fiction hier gibt es spannendes
science videos abonniert den kanal und
activity glocke nur dann verpasste
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
die vielen millionen brocken die da im
pazifik treiben sind teilweise so groß
wie basketbälle die nasa vermutet dass
sie anfang august beim ausbruch eines
unterirdischen vulkans entstanden sind
diese liegt wohl in der nähe des
inselstaates tonga und hat ihn brocken
bei einer eruption ausgespuckt konkret
handelt es sich um vulkanische bimsstein
der entsteht wenn die lava durch
wasserdampf und kohlendioxid
aufgeschäumt wird bis ins grau und
relativ leicht so dass es auf dem wasser
schön deswegen konnte es auch aufgespürt
werden und zwar durch zwei segler
larissa brill und ihr freund michael
holt waren unterwegs in richtung der
fidschi inseln als sie vorübergehend
steckenblieben dazu schreiben sie auf
facebook das feld aus steinbrocken
reichte so weit wie wir im mondlicht und
mit dem licht unserer scheinwerfer sehen
konnten das vulkanische gestein hatte
also ihr bruder kurzzeitig blockiert
doch die beiden konnten sie schnell aus
der misslichen lage befreien und hielten
dieses erlebnis fest und die fotos
lassen einen echten nur noch staunen der
gigantische gesteins teppich treibt
derzeit in richtung australien
forschungsteams hoffen dass er eine
chance für viele meereslebewesen
darstellt da sie in den vulkanischen
gestein eine neue heimat finden könnten
vor allem korallen könnten die felsen
als eine art bot nutzen dazu scott bryan
von der queensland university of
technology im australischen brisbane
wenn einige von ihnen in unserem great
barrier reef ein zuhause finden können
hilft dies beschädigte riffe zu erhalten
und wieder aufzufüllen sogar das great
barrier reef vor der australischen küste
die größte zusammenhängende ansammlung
von mehr als 2.900 einzelnen
korallenriffen und unesco weltnaturerbe
könnte also im besten fall von dem stein
teppich profitieren und diesen
sich artigen ökosystem zu einer größeren
artenvielfalt verhelfen doch dies setzt
voraus dass sich die brocken weiterhin
in richtung der australischen küste
bewegen doch der vulkan teppich birgt
auch risiken für das ökosystem das so
auch invasive arten eingeschätzt werden
könnten damit sind tier und
pflanzenarten gemeint die durch ihre
ausbreitung andere arten lebensräume und
ökosysteme beeinträchtigen auch diese
variante setzt allerdings voraus dass
die aktuellen berechnungen stimmen und
der stein teppich seinen kurs in
richtung australien fortsetzen
zunächst wird er sich analysen zufolge
an neukaledonien und vanuatu vorbei
bewegen bis dann die ersten steine an
der australischen küste ankommen können
dies wird wenn überhaupt in mehr als
einem halben jahr der fall sein also
etwa märz 2020 steht das great barrier
reef vor dem ende anklicken anschauen
und unseren schwesterkanal pixum nature
abonnieren er ist für etwas richtig
wirklich gut es sei dabei um kämpfe mit
uns für eine bessere welt bis dann
bleibt dran